and yet another installment of
everyone's racist
chris harrison won't host the next
bachelorette despite apologizing twice
for defending contestant rachel kirk
connell
after she was accused of racially
insensitive behavior
if you don't watch the show
congratulations but kirk connell is
white
currently trying to marry the black male
star making her a pretty lame
racist meanwhile an inner circle of hell
called the talk is shutting down for a
few days to investigate a conversation
when co-host
sharon osbourne defended pierce morgan
over meghan markle
i feel even like
i'm about to be put in the electric
chair because i have a friend
who many people think is a racist so
that makes
me a racist tell me when you have heard
him
say racist things educate me
i don't want anybody here to to
watch this and say that we're attacking
you for being racist
i think that creed's already sowed but
oswar's co-host cheryl underwood said
sharon was giving
validation to something he morgan has
uttered
that is racist what was said that was
racist
dumb question doesn't matter in a moral
panic
evidence becomes unnecessary all one
needs is the accusation
to burn the witch just to note the
controversial discussion was on
air so why investigate it when you can
just watch it
that's also part of the moral panic we
must do
something now or we will be next in the
barrel
it makes me wonder just by doing this
monologue in which i appear to defend
osborne
must i be investigated for giving
validation to a validation
of a person accused of racism and if
anyone here agrees with me
do they then merit an investigation for
validating my validation of sharon's
validation of a person accused and what
about you dear viewer
if you agree with me then you're
validating me
and i didn't even drive here remember
it's not about being racist
it's the power one gets making the
accusation
the power is zero sum one can only move
forward if another is cancelled
remember the red scare this is the race
scare
it rewards as it punishes and if you
don't think you're next
then you aren't paying attention now i
gotta run i have to pee
don't take my seat
all right dana i want to play for you
you know we're all going to end up
having to apologize sooner or later for
something so just get re get your
apology letter
ready and i think i came across the best
one i've ever heard
scott adams has created a an apology
letter
that we can all use and i urge you to
find it here's a snippet
i'm a deeply flawed human really just a
pile of organic crap that is barely
sentient
i must learn to listen and do better i
am committed to doing the hard
work of examining all of my flaws as
described by my critics
and i will force myself to be unhappy
until my brain is free of all
bias i am committed to a path of
self-improvement that will
with lots of hard work make me barely
acceptable to proper thinking people
i dedicate my entire life to the mission
of pleasing my critics
i plan to issue public statements of
apology for being me
until the end of my days which i think
we all agree
should come sooner than later
i think that if everybody has that in
their back pocket
uh we will all be fine dana but the
thing is chris harrison
from he did that yes he basically said
all of that and he actually said it with
more feeling
yes and like authenticity he was like
trying to bring it across and it didn't
work for him
i have a friend who watches the
bachelorette or the bachelor whatever it
is
i asked him about this he sent me eight
paragraphs
of how he feels about it and he's not
happy and he said that
um it's supposed to be like mindless
viewing right now it's no longer that
and he thinks that you know it probably
won't do as well
yeah uh katie i want to play you another
clip from the talk this is one of the
other co-hosts
talking about pierce morgan let's go
people feel that he's racist people have
receipts
i wish we had them today so that we
could actually go deeper into this
conversation so people could see
why people feel that he's racist
and sexist i mean there's a lot but
um we don't have those receipts here you
know there's a lot i mean there's these
receipts right but i don't really
need to bring them when i'm accusing
somebody of racism
i can just say we have the receipts this
is the new mccarthyism katie you don't
even need the receipts
yeah yeah it's called the talk but if
sharon osborne wants to actually talk
about it she's not allowed to and they
cancel the show for a few days
there are receipts that they're not
bringing to the conversation despite
knowing that they're going to have this
conversation
and if you go back a few steps to look
at where this conversation came from
on the talk it came from piers morgan
criticizing meghan markle
and then the co-host of the talk saying
they feel as if he is racist
the thing he is criticizing was said by
meghan markle also didn't have evidence
she claimed
that someone in the royal family said
something about her son's skin color
but wouldn't say who it was so all of
this
has no evidence and no receipts it's all
accusation
and it boils down to this awful
situation where we're no longer
able to judge anybody by their character
or
by maybe their flaws but they can get
over them we have to boil it down to you
either like someone based on their race
or you dislike them based on their race
and that's a really gross place to be
yeah you know juan katie brings up a
really good point about
the the whole racism controversy began
with just
one story from meghan markle in which
she actually smeared
not just royalty but her actual in-laws
she said her entire in-laws are all
racist because she won't say which one
over a story that she wouldn't even
discuss with them
she wouldn't even talk about whether or
not they meant it was racist or not
what kind of person would smear their
in-laws completely by saying well they
asked about
they asked this really bad question so
i'm going to tell oprah about it
to millions of people that's kind of
rotten
uh i think not acknowledging race
requires people to look away and i think
oprah and not with your mother-in-law i
think okay hang on greg
so harry and my question harry is the
one
i am trying my best harry wouldn't say
who he who said this but harry totally
backed up his wife but
with regard to these tv shows to my mind
this is not about cancel culture in any
way
and it's certainly not a serious
discussion of race this is about
capitalism
how's it about capitalism it's about
capitalism because
you know what they want they want to
stop damage to the brand of their shows
and they want to protect against the
advertisers bleeding away
because these shows have become toxic
it's a free market it's capitalism
any network any show can decide who they
want to host the show and the content of
their show as they try to make it
a success in the capital marketplace in
any case
i don't think we should be looking at
the bachelor or any of these shows
as somehow determine of what's right and
wrong and i think it's a you know in
terms of the larger discussion of race
boy it sure didn't start there greg the
uh uh
jesse um if these shows are toxic
what is making it toxic i would argue
that it is the race panic that we're
seeing right now it's the red scare
for 2021.
i agree and if this is about capitalism
as juan says
that they're doing a terrible job if
you're a cbs news executive
you let the ladies talk about it on a
show called the talk
even i would tune in to watch the women
who were paid to talk
talk about how they feel about sharon
osborne
and piers morgan that would actually get
a rating and that would make people tune
in
and maybe we learned something about it
i did find it ironic greg as you showed
the photo of
ozzy osbourne who bit the head off a bat
pete on the alamo and sang about satan
he's not canceled but his wife is for
defending one of her friends
on the bachelor nation situation dana
brought up the fact that
you know you you watch bachelor not to
to see
um the view you watch it to see women
fight over a guy
or vice versa it's like when you go to a
checkout counter at a grocery store
you pick up one of those trashy romance
novels
you open it up and it's a political
manifesto
no i want to see fabio sweep women off
their feet
and women pull each other's hair to get
into fabio's arms
that's what you want you don't want a
racial controversy
so now i'm not watching the bachelor
because i get enough racial controversy
on my day job
i didn't know they had trashy romance
novels where you shop
uh but anyway fabio how does jessie know